here's remembered as a military genius a
tactician without peer at the age of 35
having just crowned himself the first
emperor of France he said about
conquering all of Europe
his name was Napoleon Bonaparte and
above all he was a master propagandist
he made use of his extraordinary way
with words to publish political
manifestos newspapers and later his
autobiography he regularly commissioned
portraits and sculptures and was acutely
aware of how to present himself in the
best light even when he made moves to
crown himself Emperor he used propaganda
and political nouse to convince the
populace that it was their idea
Napoleon has aroused one of two emotions
hatred or loyalty everything around him
seemed bigger than life yet he had none
of the physical traits that we associate
with power he was short at five foot two
had extremely pale skin small delicate
hands and a large head set on a short
stout neck despite this his inner self
belief projected the aura of
invincibility that made him a natural
leader of men it led him to the dizzying
heights of victory and the crushing
despair of defeat in this week's
biographic Sui discover the real
Napoleon Bonaparte
[Music]
in the spring of 1769 the tiny island
nation of Corsica was under siege a
hardy band of Corsican Patriots what
determines to repel the French army that
had invaded their lands they never stood
a chance there after a year of fighting
death and carnage the rebels were
defeated the survivors crunched through
the mountains back to their homes among
them was that easier and Carlo Bonaparte
Letizia was six months pregnant it was
the day of the feast of assumption on
August the 15th 1769 when Letizia gave
birth to a second child and he was named
Napoleon Napoleon's father gave up the
flag of Corsican independence once
French victory was a shirt he refused to
fight on in the mountains with his
former Patriot holdouts the 23 year old
University student ingratiated himself
to the French overlords and quickly took
on the trappings of French privilege it
was something that his second son would
never forgive him for viewing his father
as a traitor who had betrayed his
countrymen Carlo then entered upon a law
practice before long he had won election
to the Corsican assembly he became
accepted among the elite of Corsican
society and was viewed with favor by the
French rulers yes
the more successful he became the more
it drove a wedge between him and his
second son in contrast to how he viewed
his father the young Napoleon simply
adored his mother Letizia was a
strong-willed hardy woman off her 13
pregnancies she ended up with eight
children a half disciplinarian she would
tolerate a no-nonsense yes Napoleon
would later reminisce that all of his
success in life was due to the training
that he had received at his mother's
knee
Napoleon set foot on the French mainland
for the first time in the winter of 1778
his father having secured him a position
at the prestigious Royal Military
College at Brienne in northern France
Napoleon though he hated it
accustomed to the warmth of the
Mediterranean the harsh climate shivered
him to the bone to top it off the skinny
uncoordinated country boy could hardly
speak any French any one of the facts
that he was a scholarship boy in the
country bumpkin and the loyal Corsican
with a strange accent would have been
enough to make the bullies target him
yet somehow the Polian accustomed
himself to life of Brienne his
stubbornness and tough exterior made him
immune to the taunts of his more
privileged classmates soon they along
with his teachers lost interest in the
sullen always serious Bonaparte Napoleon
he became a loner at the age of 16
napoleon began his military
apprenticeship as a second lieutenant
training with the country's most elite
artillery unit he learns his trade well
and developed into a skilled handler of
arms as well as a capable Hendra of men
yet the advancement that he had mapped
out for himself was slow in coming he
soon realized that hard work and
application were not enough to forge a
stellar military career position and
money they also played their part and he
had neither by his late teens Napoleon
found himself in a state of frustrated
inertia he knew that he was destined for
great things yet nothing was happening
for him simply he was bored to death
what a polian needed was a cataclysmic
event that would up ends the existing
order in presenting with the opportunity
to grab hold of and shape the future
little did he know though that this was
waiting just around the corner
on July the 14th 1789 Paris erupted in
revolution the spark that unleashed the
revolution in all its fury occurred when
a crowd took over an armory called Hotel
des invalid they grabbed its weapons and
stormed the Bastille prison in search of
powder and shot word spread of the crowd
success and uprisings began all over
France granaries and manor houses they
were overrun the country was in great
turmoil 20 year-old Napoleon was far
from Paris when revolution broke forth
though not a revolutionary himself he
welcomed the revolts which was shaking
the system of privileges which he so
despised after all it was this very
system that prevented him from achieving
the advancement of rank that he felt was
due to him when the French Republic was
declared in the fall of 1792 the
ambitious Corsican he wanted to play a
part
formulating a plan he took a leave of
absence from the army and returned to
Corsica which was now a part of France
he was intent on entering local politics
and rising through the ranks until he
could assert its influence on the
national stage the Corsican governor
however rebuffed Napoleon calling him a
big inexperienced boy Napoleon reacted
to this fight setting up a power base to
oppose the governor he attracted a
following of young impetus cronies but
the establishments proved too strong for
him Napoleon was forced to flee to the
mountains he and his entire family were
labeled traitors and enemies of the
fatherland setting sail for France in
June of 1793 Napoleon was tougher more
steely-eyed and more hard skinned as a
results of his unhappy experience in
Corsica the experience also caused a
mental displacement no longer a Corsican
well he was now thoroughly French that
France however well that was going to
have to be molded to make it worthy of
him
[Music]
Napoleon returned to the army as an
artillery captain he was quickly ordered
to Toulon a city of 28,000 which had
broken into open rebellion the citizens
of this southern port had thrown their
port open to the British it was the
French artilleries job to prevent the
British from gaining a foothold and to
subjugate the rebels the problem was
that the British were defending the city
from their ships cannons Napoleon knew
that he had been presented with the
opportunity that could transform his
destiny eres de critique officers had
fled France leaving a vacuum that
Napoleon was all too eager to fill all
he had to do was simply prove himself on
his commands guns and supplies were
rushed in from Provence and his Gunners
were taught to man them the regular
infantry were intensely retrained son to
Bonaparte's direct supervision he also
began to display the flashes of charisma
which would forge an unbreakable loyalty
within his ranks on December 17th he
personally led the assault of fort egg
relay his bravery and cunning were
immediately apparent throwing himself
into the fray he fought with fury
unlike most commanders the podium led
from the front a horse was shot out from
under him and an enemy bayonets lashed
him in the fie yes
he continued to attack and his forces
quickly overcame the resistance within
hours 10 British ships had been
destroyed and those that remained were
in retreat the local people they were
then subjugated it was a stunning
victory for Napoleon and one that led to
his promotion to Brigadier General in
the spring of 1795 Napoleon visited
Paris his ambition burning brighter than
ever while there he was charged with
subjugating the Parisian mobs by any
means necessary he jumped at the
opportunity grabbing cannons and muskets
in order to equip his poorly armed
forces he said his guns up inside the
two Derian positions that made it
impregnable when the attack came
Napoleon commanded his men to unleash a
merciless hail of fire upon them waiting
until he could see the whites of their
eyes he sends a barrage of grapeshot
that decimated the Parisian mob the
enemy attacked us we killed a great many
of them now all is quiet I could not be
happier Napoleon wrote to his brother
Napoleon was triumphant within a month
he had been made a full general just 26
years of age he was the commander of the
army of the interior
as a reward for his success against the
Parisian mobs Napoleon was given command
of the French army in Italy there he was
charged with defeating Frances enemies
the Austrians along with their Italian
allies and pushed them back over the
Alps this was his first opportunity to
fight on foreign soil and Napoleon was
determined to capitalize on this prior
to his arrival Napoleon's generals had
already written him off as a no-account
upstart with illusions of grandeur
when Bonaparte arrived in the flesh as
generals quickly realized their mistake
they had vastly underestimated their new
commander he quickly put them in their
place
for nearly two years their incompetence
had seen the French forces stagnating in
the Alps with nothing to show for it but
a general sense of apathy and discontent
as the generals bit their lips napoleon
addressed the fruits soldiers you are
naked and ill fed no Fame shines upon
you I will lead you into the most
fertile plains in the world rich
provinces and great cities will lie in
your power you will find their honor
glory and riches
the men were enraptured by their new
leader smiling and laughing in the midst
he was unlike anything they had ever
seen before he picked up their spirits
and made them believe in themselves
infusing them with passion he began
molding them into a formidable fighting
force meanwhile the other European
powers had become very nervous about
what was going on in France the
execution of their king and queen led to
the fears that the French experiment in
democracy would spread and threaten
their own kingdoms this led them to
quickly move against the new French
government this led to a series of force
between France and most of the major
European powers Napoleon built his army
into the most efficient conquering force
on the European mainland over the next
three years he brought stunning
victories not only in Italy but as far
as Austria and parts of North Africa his
North African invasion force was
actually a movie and spritzen which used
Egypt as a trading route though he
failed to bring Egypt under control
Napoleon was greeted as a hero on us
returned to Paris in 1799 yet he found a
nation in turmoil the government's had
no money the Austrians and the Russians
were threatening to invade and some
people even wanted to bring back the
royal family rumors were flying of a
coup with the people and the army behind
him Napoleon took charge of the grand
assembly in store
new government that was to be headed by
three provisional consuls one of these
three men was Napoleon Bonaparte himself
and it was he who everyone knew was
going to wield the power immediately
Napoleon took control he sidelined the
other two consuls personally rewriting
the Constitution to make himself the
first consult at 30 years of age
Napoleon Bonaparte had risen from his
humble Corsican backgrounds to become
the most powerful man in France
as the absolute central power in France
Napoleon had inherited a nation that had
limped from one failed attempt to
replace the rule of monarchy to another
for many people the conditions they
found themselves in at the dawn of the
19th century were worse than before the
Revolution they looked in Napoleon to
save them from their despair first
though he had to save them from the
Austrians the Austrians had regrouped
and gains back most of the lands that
Napoleon had secured during the Italian
campaign the Archduke Francis ii was
intent on crushing the Corsican usurper
who thought he could do as he pleased as
was his custom Napoleon decided to take
the offensive in the spring of 1814
strong army across the French Alps it
was a harrowing Trek his men dragging
field artillery and provisions up steep
snow-covered mountain ranges which
towered to a height of 10,500 feet men
died enroute and as the Grand Army
stumbled through the some Bernerd Pass
they were in a state of utter exhaustion
but the crossing it had made in just six
days the battle was joined on June the
14th and at the day's end 7,000 French
men lay dead the Austrians who had
finally retreated from the field of
battle left 14,000 bodies behind the
totally spent Grand Army they had won
again
the Austrians withdrew and early the
next year signed a peace treaty with
Napoleon Great Britain was the only
country remaining in the pole Ian's way
he was simply the supreme ruler of the
land mass that was Europe however Great
Britain had unquestioned command of the
Seas fabulously rich at this point due
to her colonial conquests and boasting
the greatest Navy in the world Britain
decided it was time to halt the rise of
the little General Britain declared war
on France on May the 18th 1803 and it
was at this point that Napoleon decided
it was time to invade England displaying
the laser-like focus that epitomized the
man he stated all my thoughts are
directed towards England I want only for
a favourable winds to plant the imperial
eagle on the Tower of London as it turns
out though the French invasion of Great
Britain never materialized by September
1805 war with Austria now fortified by
the Russians was once again a priority
the grand army was being rushed from the
coast to the heart of the Austrian
Empire then on October the 21st the
Royal Navy smashed the combined Spanish
British fleet in the
of Trafalgar leaving the French
essentially without a navy the British
that left them safe for now on December
the 2nd 1804 Napoleon had crowned
himself as the first emperor of the
French in a lavish ceremony in all but
name and place it was just like the
coronation of the old kings but with one
telling difference Napoleon the
controller of his own fate placed the
crown all 80 jewel-encrusted pounds of
it upon his own head
[Music]
on December the 2nd 1805 Napoleon found
himself again poised for battle against
Austria this time fortified by Russia
this would prove to be the little
generals greatest victory he
deliberately abandoned a strategic
position near the town of Austerlitz in
the Austrian Empire so that his army
which numbered around 68,000 would
appear vulnerable
he then weakened his right flank so as
to lure the ninety thousand strong foe
into a trap as they left their centre
open to counter-attack and the Polian
cut their line in two by 4:30 p.m. the
Allies were either dead or far in
retreat the battlefields had simply
fallen silent the battle of Austerlitz
just like that was over what had begun
as a great Allied opportunity to finally
defeat and destroy Napoleon Bonaparte
that end is not only in their defeat
but in catastrophe the grounds victory
at Austerlitz was followed up with a
21-day subjugation of Prussia over the
next five years victory followed victory
as one by one the European powers bowed
to the dictates of Emperor Napoleon only
one European nation remained to be
brought to heel Russia
Napoleon and a colossal army crossed the
Neman River on June the 24th 1812 to
intimidate Russia but it turns out to be
the undoing of his empire the Russians
systematically retreated and scorched
the earth which drags the French deep
into their territory then when they did
do battle it was the bloodiest day of
Napoleon's career the French entered
Moscow
a week later only to find it evacuated
the retreat ended up being even more
costly soldiers had insufficient
clothing for the freezing temperatures
of an early winter disease devastated
the ranks and Russian forces pursued
them all the way a little over a sixth
of the 600,000 men who marched into
Russia came home this was a blow from
which the little general would never
recover by now the political map of
Europe had changed the British the
Spanish the Portuguese pushed the French
back over the Pyrenees in the Peninsular
war a grand coalition was formed with
the decisive victory coming at the
Battle of Leipzig in October of 1813
known as the Battle of the nations at
left 38,000 French dead or wounded and
20,000 captured
[Music]
Napoleon escaped only to find open
hostility back in Paris the Legislative
Assembly the Senate and even his own
general stands on him yes no choice but
to abdicate which he did on April the
6th 1840 it was agreed that Napoleon
would be sent into exile on the
Mediterranean island of Elba after 10
months of ex arm the Polian it had
enough somehow on the night of February
the 26th 1815 he managed to sneak past
his guards and set sail in a small boat
for the mother country with him were a
handful of loyal soldiers miraculously
they managed to avoid the British
warships stepping foot back on French
soil he fixed his sights on Paris and
taking back what had been torn from him
after six days in disputed by an
infantry regiments with strict orders to
detain him
Napoleon straight ahead of his followers
and stood in their midst soldiers he
declared if there is one among you who
wants to kill his general and Emperor
Here I am his charisma have done it
again rather than rush to take him
captive the massed infantry broke into
wild applause cheers of long live the
Emperor
filled the air suddenly he had an army
as he closed in on Paris he drew more
and more support in one place after
another troops defected from the Royal
Army and joined the rebel army the
writing that was on the wall by the time
he arrived in Paris lui the xviii had
fled napoleon was back in command the
people they welcomed him as a redeemed
hero
[Music]
across Europe the Allies were in shock
and disbelief the devil it had been
Unchained they would have to unite one
more time to stop him this time though
they would have to totally destroy the
man so that there was no chance he would
come back Napoleon was declared an House
law and a disturber of the tranquility
of the world they massed their armies
for attack the great reckoning it was at
hand it would be delivered on a field of
rye and clover just outside of a small
Belgian town called Waterloo on June the
18th 72,000 French soldiers faced a
68,000 strong allied force under the
Duke of Wellington while the fighting
seemed even Napoleon made many tactical
errors including launching his Imperial
Guard too late
his most fatal error was to wait until
midday before or during his initial
attack in orders the latter the muddy
ground dry
this gave the Prussians time to enter
the fray later on they smashed against
his right flank and the battle was lost
four days later Napoleon abdicated again
but this time there would be no return
he was packed off to the remote British
colony of santolina at 46 Napoleon was
simply a man without a future
the man of unstoppable ambition the man
of action the man of headlines he was
confined to reading the newspaper and
gardening he died on May the 5th 1821
most likely from stomach cancer days
before when he knew his time was up
he had whispered to one of his guards to
die is nothing but to live defeated and
without glory is to die every day so I
really hope you enjoyed that episode of
biographic if you did there's a couple
of things you could do right now one is
hit that like button below also if you
want more stuff like this we put out
brand new videos every Monday and every
Thursday so hit that subscribe button
below and subscribe button doesn't do
what it used to on YouTube if you
actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]
you